taryn thème apparemment
à l'origine galles
est-ce que par amour pour lui vous
seriez prête à vous déguiser en est je
regarde déjà
est-ce que par amour pour lui vous
seriez prête à arrêter de chanter non
non est ce que vous seriez prêtre par
amour à vous convertir à l'islam et à
passer votre vie voit les noms l'a voulu
mais pas tant que ça finalement
en fait non
est ce que vous seriez prêtre par amour
à vous faire refaire les seins non et
parmi
vous seriez prête à prendre 17 kg tu
vous le demandait nom et par gourmandise
bien sûr ça oui si
vous seriez prête paramo a caché le
corps de quelqu'un qu'il vient de tuer
non non est-ce que par amour vous
accepteriez qu'il est une maîtresse
dont vous seriez pas d'accord pour vivre
à trois avec la maîtresse non plus un
bien fou
à lier iai est ce que par amour vous
seriez prête à faire des partouzes
non allez y ait la dernière question
c'est la pire kevin êtes prête
est-ce que vous soyez prêtre par amour à
devenir son esclave sexuelle
alors qu
bah oui
non